et
[Musique]
soir
rien n'est mort de ce qui respire encore
et ce sont ses mots en fête qui font de
moi ce que je suis aujourd'hui et je
l'espère que ce sont ses mots
kim emporteront jusqu'à mon dernier
souffle et c'est sur ces mots qui ont
fait que je suis passé d'un jeune de
banlieue à directeur directeur de quatre
établissements ici en france pour
personnes en situation d'autisme et
fondateur de plusieurs structures à
l'étranger donc en algérie au maroc en
mauritanie et en arabie saoudite
alors vous vous demandez comment on fait
pour passer de jeunes de rappeurs à
directeur d'établissement avec les deux
pieds dans le plat
ben moi le doubt celui qui était
dyslexique et dysorthographiques j'ai 12
ans et je suis dans ces classes vous
savez les incas âmes n'est certes pas là
où vous apprend à devenir un perdu de la
société sans aux caméras ge de réussite
ou bien de devenir le guerrier résilient
moi j'ai décidé d'être un guerrier
résilient de prendre les armes avec mais
demain mais je vois ma colère mais peine
et d'avancer et en fait j'ai 12 ans et
je sais même pas au chu chez même parce
qu'on me demande je comprends rien je
suis perdu et pour ceux qui m'entourent
je suis qu'un jeune beur de seconde zone
je suis rebelles un violent et grâce à
tous ceux qui m'ont mis en fait dans
cette case j'apprends à dire non et non
je suis pas un beurre de seconde zone
non je ne suis pas violent non je ne
suis pas un rebelle et apprendre à dire
non en fait c'est apprendre à dire oui
eh ben oui je suis moi moi avec mes
difficultés
oui je suis dyslexique oui je suis d
orthographe hic
oui j'ai envie d'écrire et oui j'ai le
droit d'être celui que j'ai envie d'être
et j'ai 16 ans
foutu pour foutu j'apporte mon premier
groupe de rap je l'appelle daoud m6
j'écris mes premiers textes de rap j'y
mets ma colère ma joie nommé peine tout
ce que j'ai dans le ventre depuis que je
suis petit et en fait mes textes ont
toute légitimité
je suis un jeune de banlieue problème
j'ai 17 ans et là je saisis
l'opportunité qu'on me donne celle
d'écrire des ateliers d'écriture avec
des personnes autistes
alors je me rappelle quand j'en parlais
autant demande y est t'es fou toile des
autistes ils font pas durable en fait on
y voyait absolument pas le jeudi tous
ces jeunes qui m'attendait devant le
portail à 13 heures pour pouvoir jouer
du micro alors moi je m'en rappelle et
je vous raconte la première rencontre
que j'ai eue avec ce jeune autiste et je
m'en souviens comme à la naissance de
mon premier fils je suis rentré dans une
grande salle polyvalente
il y avait une belle fresque au mur il y
avait des têtes des chiffres des
couleurs des animaux s'étaient cosmique
bizarre je commence mon atelier pépère
au bout de deux secondes pam
je vois ce jeune là se met dans une
colère monstrueuse trois éducateurs pour
le calmer aa je me dis comment c'est
possible
comment le cerveau est fait pour passer
d'un état calme pépère à ce niveau là je
voulais comprendre
j'avance et je gagne en légitimité à
l'hôpital de jour j avance et moi j'ai
pas peur j'ai pas peur de cette violence
que je me prends en pleine tronche
parce qu'en fait elle est tellement
différente de celle que je côtoie
d'habitude que ce soit dans ma cité au
foyer ou dans la rue celle là les halles
né d'une frustration à l'idée d'une
pulsion
donc elle m'interroge et j'ai envie de
comprendre je continue à avancer je fais
ces fameuses rencontres aspirante comme
bon passeur d'avenir le docteur moïse
assouline que j'ai connu à 17 ans quand
j'étais à l'hôpital de jour et grâce à
maurice je rencontre un autre personnage
qui est à voir butten
celui qui a écrit le best-seller quand
j'avais 5 ans je m'habitue et et grâce à
howard en fait j'apprends le théâtre aux
huit mois le dyslexiques le dise
orthographique jeu j'aime écrire j'ai à
vous de vous à moi mes textes de rap au
début c'était un peu des hiéroglyphes
c'est spécial mais j'avance comme m et
puis du coup je gagne en légitimité
mais je passe un diplôme ce diplôme de
moniteur éducateur et j'avoue niveau des
cols étaient tendus fallait écrire enfin
les gratter mais le dr assouline
derrière un pouce il me dit vas-y et
devenir mon correcteur automatique
d'orthographe
j'avance j'ai 20 ans j'ai enfin trouvé
ma place je suis tellement fier de ce
que j'ai accompli que ma vie de rappeurs
s'arrête là
ok je respire plus de rap mais je me
mets à fond dans l'éducation spécialisée
et notamment dans les cas complexes et
les cas un peu violent et je me rappelle
de ce jeune on va l'appeler michael qui
est à l'hôpital psychiatrique
les médecins avaient conclu que michael
devait sortir parce que les médicaments
des plus des faits qu'il était enfermé
qu'elle était dans sa chambre il joue
avec ses selles il tapait la tête contre
le robinet il se faisait mal passé son
temps à se masturber quand il sortait
dehors il ouvrait la porte de la voiture
et prenait la boucle de la ceinture
la bt dans son doigt et tournez tournez
que dans une jusqu'à son sens et casser
les bouts de verre hilweh frotter comme
ça ça faisait mal à la tête et ça
résonnait est en fait je me disais que
michael ils se mettaient pas en danger
et qu'il avait pas la notion du danger
donc moi gentil bienveillant je voulais
le mettre dans un contexte où lui ne
maîtrisait pas l'environnement
j'ai rien trouvé d'autre crime l'emmener
à la foire du trône
et je lui ai fait faire le grand huit
vous savez le manège à sensations là
avec mon pote
et ça a marché quand michael est
descendu il était tout blanc il avait le
coeur qui battait les yeux étaient
livides il est resté calme 35 minutes 35
minutes
l'état dans laquelle il a été arrêté
pendant un an je me suis dit on va me
prendre pour un menteur donc j'ai filmé
pour le montreux docteur assouline et et
à ses parents et du coup de manière
concrète grâce à mikel on a monté le
relais ile-de-france relais ile de
france association qui prend en charge
des personnes en situation d'autisme cas
complexes durant les week-ends mais
quand j'ai monté le relais on m'a dit
t'es pas légitime tant que moniteur
éducateur est faux et éducateur
spécialisé
je suis retourné à l'école j'ai gratté
j'ai cogné j'ai eu mon diplôme des ducs
spé après on a pris leur structure
pendant la semaine parce que j'en avais
qui est enfermé on m'a dit c'est bien
mais il faut être chef de service
j'avais pas de pottas - chef de service
dans ma cité ça existe pas je suis
retourné à l'école j'ai gratté
j'ai cogné j'ai obtenu mon diplôme de
chef de service
et puis après une association qui
grandit fo salariés déjà en faut
investir dans des véhicules
il faut avoir des accréditations et
subventions faut un master 2 ouah
un accouchement je suis retourné par
l'école à l'université
envoyez-les angoissant pour un mec est
dyslexique et des orteaux graphique je
retourne à l'école toujours le docteur à
s'unir derrière
heureusement pour les fautes
d'orthographe et là ça a été un
accouchement très honnêtement et j'ai
obtenu mon master 2 ingénierie des dames
à personne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et du coup on a créé un pont concret
entre les jeunes de quartiers populaires
qui venait accompagner avec moi ces
jeunes en situation d'autisme et je me
rappelle pas ce que ces jeunes là en
situation d'autisme personne ne veut
s'en occuper à la base alors que les
jeunes de quartiers populaires où
étaient partants ces mêmes jeunes à qui
on dit tout le temps qu'ils ne savent
rien faire ils ne peuvent rien faire ils
doivent tenir les murs un passé faux
oeufs en fait il avait envie de le faire
ils sont confiants il faut leur donner
confiance
et puis on banalise et parce qu'eux
aussi ont une colère intérieure contre
la société ils ont tellement banalisé la
violence que quand nos jeunes avaient
des troubles du comportement ça leur
pose est pas vrai souci n'arrive à la
détourner avec un câlins bisous un petit
massage pour aller hop on passe à autre
chose et je me rappelle que les
psychiatres et les directeurs
d'établissement il disait mais comment
c'est possible
peut-être comment ces jeunes de
quartiers compact diplôme arrive à gérer
des cas complexes
très honnêtement je pense qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'empathie de leur part et que
alors c'est vrai ils arrivent en mode
tout le monde connaît un peu ou échouage
protecteur et tout ça mais avec le temps
il arrive à se poser à devenir
professionnel moi je pense qu'en
analysant cette situation là en fait ces
deux forces négatives qui font une port
une force positif je pense aussi que ces
deux populations vulnérables quand elle
se rend compte à fond une poche une
population positif ces fameuses règles
du relais 1 pour 1 ou un plus un égale
un lait pour moi c'est la fameuse rien
n'est mort de ce qui respire encore
alors les gens n'ont pas cru en moi j'y
ai cru on l'a fait et ça fonctionne
et puis après j'ai été plus loin avec
stéphane benhamou et ryad kanoute mes
deux frères de guerre comme je les
appelle
on a monté un club de vacances pour
éviter l'enfermement pendant le week-end
et soulager les parents et ça fonctionne
et puis je me suis lancé un autre défi
j'en ai d'autres mais celui là je les
fais aussi c'était de former les
professionnels sur les cas complexes
parce que je me suis dit que si on
formait les gens eh bien on évite l
expulsion dans les institutions
sauf que pour les cas complexes bah tu
prends tout tu prends les cacas les
bisous les bizarreries les colères la
détresse des parents
tu prends tout ou tu laisses tout alors
c'est vrai j'avoue je suis un peu hors
normes
j'ai bougé beaucoup d'institutions
j'avoue mais je pense sincèrement au
fond de moi qu'il n'y a pas d'idée
préconçue
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de cadres
fichiers qu'il n'ya pas d'élite alors on
pourrait se poser la question mais
pourquoi pourquoi il fait tout ça parce
que c'est ma vie voilà et parce que
aussi je pense que on n'est pas
propriétaire
la vie on nous la donne on est
dépositaire et riz tributaire de ce que
la vie peut nous donner
je pense aussi sincèrement qu'il n'ya
pas absolument pas de fatalisme de
fatalité pardon pour personne et que
alors je reprends je me suis perdu je
vais juste un petit tour au bessat voir
venir regarder ça en prend voilà ce que
je pense sincèrement moi c'est qu' il
n'y a pas de fatalité et il n'y a pas de
fatalisme et déterminisme social pour
personne c'est la première chose est
vraiment pour personne et la seconde
chose qui est très importante c'est que
je pense que rien n'est mort de ce qui
respire encore et moi jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je respire merci
[Musique]